in the three years since persona fives
original release I've thought about it
almost every day its lavish style
captures its spirit of rebellion and
breathes life into its dynamic combat
system the evocative bangin soundtrack
perfectly encapsulates the emotion of
each moment the down time spent in Tokyo
with all your friends brings you closer
to them invigorating your fight for
what's right all those qualities feed
into a bold story that unapologetically
puts its foot down against the injustice
--is that reflect our own society the
extended version persona 5 royal brings
the heat all over again but beyond a
plethora of superb gameplay refinements
and features that improve an already
rich RPG comes a momentous new story are
exceeded within the original narrative
and paid off in full by the end it
delivers something genuinely surprising
leading to incredible moments and
emotional conclusions that
recontextualize what I thought the game
was and through its lengthy 120 hour
runtime persona 5 royal proves itself as
the definitive version of a modern
classic
see
[Music]
because p5 are expertly intertwined
social sim elements an RPG
dungeon-crawling
you grow attached to the very world
you're fighting to change it's been the
series foundation since persona 3 and
most effective here in p5 are balancing
school life relationships and your
duties as a phantom thief throughout the
calendar year even makes the mundane
exciting
you'll spend time with characters to
learn about what drives them and witness
their growth as they internalize and
overcome their trauma among your
connections are kind-hearted adults
exhausted by a system that has failed
them and teenagers haunted by their past
and dreading their future these are very
human stories that inspire in their own
small way and these relationships with
your confidants bestow powers you carry
into battle p5 are makes the confidante
process easier with new scenes to help
rank them up faster effectively granting
the opportunity to see more of these
enticing stories which is important
because there are a few new confidants
as well
gorel kechi is now someone you choose to
spend time with which eventually leads
to a better understanding of him this
time around Kasumi Yoshizawa has been
touted as the big addition to the roster
she fits in well and you'll see that her
desire to be an elite competitive
gymnast comes from a complicated place
although her screen time is limited in
the first half of the game
she becomes vital to the delivery of the
new story arcs and a welcome Ally to
fight alongside the rest of the gang you
know and love but above all is the
school counselor Taku tomorrow ki a
tremendous character who truly elevates
p5 our narrative Lee he's an excellent
thematic fit offering perspectives on
mental health that hadn't been touched
in the original his story is cleverly
integrated into the core narrative
he's also key for what lies beyond
persona 5s original story and some of p5
r's best moments you have a strong moral
compass never losing sight of your own
definition of justice I'm more grateful
than ever to have met a young man like
yourself in the Metaverse the physical
manifestation of corrupted cognition
hard fought battles take place you
metaphysically crushed the distorted
desires of perpetrators who have
oppressed your friends and many others
and you do it with a hyper stylized
confident swagger taking on the story
critical palaces never loses its luster
and at times their very premise is
subverted to create effect palaces
features some
small but smart changes in p5 are
rearranged dungeon layouts accommodate
Joker's new grappling-hook letting you
access the areas they often lead to will
seeds a new collectible that replenishes
SP and mold into a useful accessory
returning players may also notice
streamlining of some dungeon layouts
making exploration smoother mementos the
meta versus collection of procedurally
generated floors also get some
much-needed overhauls driving through as
the Morgana bus was novel but eventually
grew repetitive in the original game p5
are throws in some new mechanics like
collecting flowers and stamps to cash in
for useful items and perks to boost
battle rewards and the most welcomed
change is that there are new tunes that
play at deeper levels
aside from stealthily navigating these
surreal dungeons you'll be spending a
ton of time engaged in p5 ARS dynamic
turn-based battles it's Swift and
stylish and builds on the strong
foundation of Shin Megami Tensei which
has you focusing on exploiting elemental
weaknesses and earning extra turns p5
are layers even more onto battles with
the absurd showtime attacks and a
powered up baton pass mechanic and boss
fights have different phases that
present new tough challenges that test
your mastery of the combat system
everything unfolds in such stylish
fashion that you can't help but fall in
love with it and the Phantom thieves who
pull off all these stunning moves even
the UI looks cool as hell but it's also
snappy and efficient helping keep up
combats fast pace and even in the second
version of the game executing all-out
attacks and watching them unfold hasn't
lost a bit of its charm
never has a turn-based combat system
been this thrilling
[Music]
but P 5r isn't here to just look pretty
beneath the mask of it's unrelenting
style and charming silliness are the
friendships you naturally form which
motivate you to take the fight to the
very end from their persona awakenings
to the moment you see them fully realize
their goals your fellow phantom thieves
become your ride or die in this heavy
empowering story in targeting the
perpetrators of sexual assault worker
exploitation and Viola thorat Arianism
persona 5 draws a clear line in the sand
people like this have no place in our
society and deserve no mercy there is no
middle ground milk compromised to be
made even when personal drama or doubt
starts to creep in characters work
through it and stick to their ideals
admittedly P 5r is often subtle as a
brick it's easy to nitpick where it's
writing falls into being too simplistic
although it has improved in some ways it
could still be crude at times it isn't
particularly nuanced in its storytelling
but it doesn't have to be in being clear
as day in its narrative its messages and
characterizations are unmistakable now
transitioning to the Royal exclusive 3rd
semester there's a tonal shift that's
effortlessly executed it's oddly
unsettling especially during a seemingly
blissful winter here P 5r takes a turn
toward genuine moral quandaries there's
a bit more to learn about your friends
and there's one final palace to
infiltrate and it is without a doubt the
best one in the entire game the
mysteries within will surprise you with
fascinating revelations about characters
that propel them well beyond their first
impression and a grand sense of finality
leads into what's also the best boss
battle in all of P 5r it effectively
solves one of the shortcomings of the
original game it's somewhat abrupt end
there's 15 to 20 hours worth of a
central content that takes persona 5 in
a new direction while going all in on
the game's best qualities it gives a
dramatic stunning finish even after the
originals bombastic over-the-top
conclusion and these events are
beautifully captured with new Royal
exclusive songs that amplify what was
all
an iconic genre-bending soundtrack like
our old favorites life will change or
rivers in the desert the new evocative
jams become a powerful narrative device
I believe and throw away your mask carry
the emotional weight in their lyrics &
composition and when you hear them in
their moment they'll stick with you
well after
[Music]
music is inseparable from the persona
experience
the series thrives because of it and
somehow someway p5 art delivers again to
make an even stronger impact as p5 art
comes to a close it tries to ease you
into its end with heartwarming scenes
some new some familiar but in doing so
it only makes it harder to say goodbye
again persona 5 Royals many things a
collection of small inspiring stories an
ambitious heartfelt journey with some
good friends a stunning visual and
auditory experience a resounding call to
action by refining what was already
great and building on its best qualities
with a brilliant new story arc persona 5
royal asserts itself as an unforgettable
and empowering RPG that should be
recognized as one of the best games of
our time
[Music]
you